I actually really like this article it
says Alex Jones claims Infowars host
Owen Shroyer was charged for free speech
that's it they don't insult Alex Jones
they don't write anything they literally
just post a quote and a video of Alex
Jones which uh I will play a bit for you
here right now I think uh now this deals
with Owen and and this deals with the
rest of January six people where their
lawyers are like we don't want you to
antagonize the system
we don't want you to sit there and do a
bunch of stuff let us try to not get
them in prison I'm like well I want to
defend them I want to talk about it well
it's up to them they want help or not
and and Owen's a Smart Cookie but
they're trying to put Owen in jail in
prison they filed last night he
sentenced next week
goes to DC
and
I didn't cover it but the Gateway pundit
did Breaking DC prosecutors seek 120
days in prison for Owen Shroyer for
speeding out against Stone election 2020
that's not just
the Gateway upon its headline
I have overhead shot please right here
the charging document the feds put
forward here it is we actually have that
as well and so in the charging document
I'm not going to read through the whole
thing
they basically say before January 6 on
January 6th and after January 6 Owen
Shroyer had said things that
incited people
and uh for that they are seeking this
sentence the criminal charge against him
is not for speech it's for uh being on
the capitol grounds but they're arguing
that he is the reason people stormed the
capital
they highlight this be a part of History
fight for Trump and it shows people
outside the capitol uh Alex Jones and
Owen with bullhorns
and if you scroll down
I'll jump down to uh right before they
get to their their recommendations they
go on to mention uh let's see uh I want
to try and find the specific portion May
go on a mention after the fact August
so this is for his speech that they are
seeking to put him in jail
when I said that the next people they'd
come for would be pundits I didn't I
didn't mean like outright it would be
Owen's or anything like that there are
people who are not in the capital we're
not on the capitol grounds who I am
referring to and there are people who
are not even in DC who I am referring to
I even said like prominent cable
personalities who are in Communications
with Trump legals team who who pushed
the narrative prominent personalities
many of whom got sued they're gonna come
after them next but Owen Shroyer is in
between he Not only was there on the
ground he didn't go in the building but
he was also someone at their seeking a
prison sentence for over speech he made
after the fact
I blame Obama
yeah it wasn't uh because the precedent
for going after journalists was set with
uh Snowden and with uh Assange and then
the Obama Administration went after
James Rosen so the idea that this is the
first time no this is something that's
been in motion for a long time and
there's a lot of people people around
this table and and other pundits and
stuff that have have been vocal about
how it's a bad thing that you know
Snowden hasn't been uh pardoned and
Assange hasn't been pardoned and it's a
bad thing that that Rosen went to jail
and the Democrats didn't actually went
to jail I'm sorry that they uh they went
after him we've had him on the show I'm
pretty sure yeah I was here and he was
talking about you know they wiretapped
them and blah blah and uh you know
the fact that we have allowed the
government to get away with it is why it
continues now the situation we're in
right here if this does happen and he
goes to jail for speech
it's only going to be worse they're not
there's not going to be someone that
says okay
that's enough
BS they're gonna be like all right that
worked the American people allowed it
this is a new power we have and we can
do this so let's go back in time let's
go back to when the when the bite
Administration targeted James Rosen a
journalist tried to put him in jail when
Obama uh charged whistleblowers and
journalists under the Espionage Act more
than any other president combined than
all the other presidents combined yeah
imagine going back then when we were
concerned about this and telling people
in 10 years they're going to put a guy
in jail because he was on the capitol
grounds bull Horning
and then after the fact he said you he
said he said stuff like to a certain
degree we should be proud of what we did
that day
he said something like he's he maintains
the election was stolen one of the
reasons they want him in jail is because
they said even after all this he still
maintains the election was stolen as if
he has to publicly change his opinion
yeah this is
this is Soviet level this is culture
Revolution level
communist authoritarianism welcome to
the Future and it happens very quickly
very quickly it goes from you're free to
you're not free
I mean look we're discussing 10 years
now you I mean and and think about the
past few years yeah think about where we
were six seven years ago and it's it's
laughable
to me that there are people who are like
ah you're overreacting or you're you
know it's exaggerating or it's shot
content I'm like dude
I think the issue is that
everybody is standing in the middle of
the forest and when you tell them dude
you are in the middle of force like what
do you mean just can't full of trees
like one two three four five six seven
eight nine I'm like bro you can't tell
where all the other trees are because
you're standing in the middle of all of
them yeah you got to look at nine I mean
911 is like
you know when you see those buildings
fall in free fall I I most people can
understand it when they see the site
okay hold on nah like you want to talk
about you just jump slow boil way too
far that's the beginning of this
totalitarian seizure man I can't respect
that but you got to slow down a little
bit the way that the government you got
to talk about okay so we ended up in the
position with the ndaa the National
Defense authorization act 2010 or so
2000 I think that was 12. which gave the
indefinite which signed into law the
indefinite detention provision which is
an offshoot of what is effectively the
bush era expansion of authoritarianism
anti-terror policies and the expansion
of the creation of DHS which emerges out
of the Patriot Act which starts I
watched it happen in real time too it
was crazy and like I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm saying we got it we gotta work
we gotta explain to people how we get
from point A to point B right this would
set like a precedent for that to be
acceptable if they were to pull that off
and now it is now now we're here when
when we talked in 2012 about the the
indefinite detention provision that
Obama signed into law the NDA provision
that says they could snatch you up in
the middle of the night without charge
or trial hold you on a military vessel
11 miles off the coast of this country
and rendition you
we were like that's scary and the
response to everybody is oh you're nuts
that's never gonna happen shut your
mouths because now we're at the point
where they're arresting journalists
they're arrested well they've been
targeting journalists that's the Obama
era around the same time going after a
Rosen Julian Assange that's that's an
informal assassination as far as I'm
concerned Owen Shroyer said bombastic
things outside the Capitol and for that
they want to go to prison this is the
next grain of sand they're going after
lawyers they're going after political uh
they're going after politicians it's not
just Trump They removed Coy Griffin in
New Mexico from the ballot this is well
beyond the point we are we are
potentially a couple years away from the
actual implementation of an indefinite
detention Act
the Trump and and I hate the fact that
this is so prescient now but Trump said
they're not coming after you or they're
not coming after me they're coming after
you I'm just in the way and I hate the
fact that it looks like that's the case
the idea that it's just Trump is
something that that I've been pushing
back against with Democrats specifically
shitlabs uh for a long time because they
think oh well Donald Trump is different
Donald Trump is different it's like the
thing that's different is the behavior
of the Democrats on the left the
influence of authoritarianism in the
United States on the left is undeniable
and the the fact that people have been
ignoring it or just saying no no it's
not true likely because they don't
believe it's true because they have
normal jobs and normal lives and they're
not steeped in this stuff like people
that do this stuff all the time but the
fact of the matter is
the federal government has never been
more authoritarian they're throwing
people in jail in the way that they did
like during the uh the Civil War and in
the 20s or not was it was it Wilson that
threw people in jail FDR threw people in
jail but it's back to the old you know
authoritarian government and that's not
acceptable they're iced and I said we've
said this a bunch I don't see the off
ramp if this is accepted
what's going to be next because it's not
going to be oh we're going to chill out
it would take someone in at the Democrat
Party with in power standing up and
saying we can't do this and there is no
one that even wants to they're all
enjoying it I think it's going to come
from us to be honest that's scary yeah
it is scary but you know what nobody's
coming to save you and you see this
everywhere where authoritarianism just
takes hold you know everybody's like
well we just need a savior and that's
why you get that charismatic leader that
comes in and destroys the country and
you know maybe that charismatic leader
that we need to save us As Trump but I
doubt it no he was in power before and
he did nothing for Julian Assange he did
nothing for Edwards Edward Snowden he
did nothing for Ross Albrecht he's done
nothing to change the situation that
we're in now he had the opportunity four
years was plenty yeah but there's nobody
else there is nobody else I agree with
you there's nobody else and at this
point it's Trump or nobody but we can't
expect that Trump is going to come save
us we have to understand that it's going
to come from us and it's going to come
from Americans number one understanding
history understanding where this is
going and then doing something about it
because they can't control us if we
don't allow them to you you were talking
earlier about uh Venezuela can you go
ahead and relate some of the things that
you were telling us about because this
is pre this is important now because
this is something that it's it's
possible that we're gonna have to worry
about we have got there are people that
that and I really do want you to do but
I want to say this first people that
that deny that there's a problem on the
left they need to go to urban areas and
talk to the P the political activists
the people that are on the ground
working with the with the communities
talk to them you go to you go to
Brooklyn there's DSA everywhere which is
the Democratic socialists of America
full of commies full of Communists and
and they're they're at the point where
they'll tell you about it so if you
don't mind go ahead and somehow it's
okay to be a communist in this country
like you would never call yourself
according to me you know well let's
let's start from the beginning uh it
wasn't that long ago people don't
realize this that Venezuela was a
wealthy capitalist Nation absolutely so
I wasn't born in Venezuela because my
mom hightailed it back to the U.S to
have me
um but I was I was taken to Venezuela
when I was nine days old and I lived
there until back and forth between the
us until I was 15. so you know I'm
however like my age old is how like long
this has been going on not even much
less I watched communism socialism enter
into Venezuela Venezuela was one of the
most prosperous nations in Latin America
before Venezuela it was Cuba which was
of course destroyed by the same ideology
and there's no way to talk about
Venezuela without talking about Cuba
because Fidel Castro the dictator of
Cuba trained Hugo Chavez
um in Cuba on how to do this you know
it's I I think people just assume that
it's easy to come into power and take
over
um and and it he did it in the very
similar ways to Castro so yeah it starts
very similarly and it's this class
Warfare it starts with the well you're
poor because that guy over there has
your money that guy over there it has
your your jobs and your opportunities
and you know you're poor because of them
so you see the class Warfare and that's
that's really where you know it started
like Dawning on me here in the US like
oh wait I've seen this before it's that
that and then it you know it
authoritarianisms come in and of course
you can't you your guns is the first
thing they take
you know unfortunately here in the US we
have started to lose a little bit of our
our gun freedoms and I understand that
that's scary for some people but I I
disagree on that one it's actually not
true what uh gun rights have expanded
rapidly and exponentially over the past
two decades in ways that this country
is is it's been good right so uh DC
versus Heller the right to for
individuals to keep and bear arms
outside of their home was 2008. if you
look at the issuance of gun permits
there was not a single state that would
allow you to have a gun for the most
part back in the 80s it was it was
actually difficult to have guns now we
did have a different culture where
people had rifles and there was like uh
gun clubs in schools but uh in the past
20 years the expansion of individual
liberties and gun rights has been
exponential to the point where now I
think half the country is constitutional
carry to or or I'm sorry it's probably
safer to say uh uh open carry in more
than half the country which did not
exist 20 30 years ago thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time